- Do I look unhealthy?
Take a look at this physique.
I'm in phenomenal shape, in body and mind.
People say a loss can
make or break a fighter.
But trust me, a win can also
If you can see it here,
and you have the courage
enough to speak it,
it will happen.
Nobody works harder than me.
Inside the octagon, outside
the octagon, I am a workhorse.
I knew what was going to happen.
I knew I was going to get here.
They didn't.
It was a lot of stressful years.
A lot of tough times.
Every gym had their set
way of doing things.
Don't do it this way, do it that way.
I always felt grateful
for even the small things.
I always used to celebrate
the small things.
And I slipped a punch and
I shuffled my shoulders
and I said, "Muhammad Ali!"
and threw a shot.
People set goals, long
distance goals and shit.
That's too much for me.
I appreciate the support
of all the fans out here
and all over the world.
I never take it for granted.
I use it as motivation, so.
- He's an Irish mixed martial artist.
He competes in the
Featherweight and Lightweight
divisions of the UFC.
He's the current UFC
Featherweight champion.
He's Conor McGregor and here are his
Top 10 rules for success.
(jet engine revving)
- [Interviewer] What makes
you such a good fighter?
- [Conor] I don't know,
I'm just curious about it.
It's in my head 24/7.
There's nothing else I can think.
I don't think about nothing else.
That's it, I'm just curious.
Curiously fascinated, really, and I can't
stop thinking about it.
Everything I do in my
life is related to this.
I don't do nothing else if it's
not got to do with fighting.
Know what I mean?
That is why.
To be truth, all you got to do is show up.
- [Interviewer] Is that not unhealthy?
- I don't know, do I look unhealthy?
Take a look at this physique.
I'm in phenomenal shape in body and mind.
To me, what's unhealthy is
living an unhealthy life.
getting up and going through
the same day every day of your life 9 to 5
in an office.
That's unhealthy.
That beats your mind.
I don't work.
I love what I do and that's
why I'm doing what I love,
know what I mean?
And that's why it's
become a career for me,
because I love it.
I love what I do so I
don't think it's unhealthy.
I feel good in my mind.
It's my life.
(Irish music)
- [Commentator] Presents as well.
- [Commentator] McGregor
really throwing the legs
to the side landing a nice, big shot.
- [Commentator] He's
trying to hurt Jahnsen
with some shots.
He's just covering at the moment.
- [Commentator] Oh, lovely
left knee to the ribs.
He was sitting in that
sideways position, but now just
hitting the head and landing big strikes.
It's going to McGregor.
Jahnsen's going to have
to do something here.
- [Commentator] And that's it!
Newhall has called a halt to this.
Jahnsen was not intelligently
defending himself
and Conor McGregor wins
by ground and pound
and asks for a reaction from
the crowd, which he gets.
- You stare at your past and
you'll end up staying there.
It's okay to look back and
admire it, but you carry on.
I'm not in the business
of staring back at it,
you know what I mean?
And getting lost back there.
People say a loss can
make or break a fighter,
but trust me, a win can
also make or break a fighter
because they get comfortable with a win.
People can get comfortable with a win and
slack off then.
Slack off on the training,
slack off on the diet.
They've won one, they're winners now.
That's not me.
You sleep on a win and
you wake up with a loss,
so I just carry on, keep
doing what I'm doing.
And that's why this
tournament is so good for me.
Vegas straight away.
The fighting Irish headed
to the fighting capital.
It's perfect.
Continue on this path, the freight train
straight to the top.
(dramatic music)
If you can see it here and you have
the courage enough to
speak it, it will happen.
So, I see these shots,
I see these sequences,
and I don't shy away from them.
A lot of times people
believe in certain things,
but they keep to themselves.
They don't put it out there.
If you truly believe in it, if you become
vocal with it, you're creating
that law of attraction
and it will become reality.
I knew he would overextend
and I knew I'd catch him.
So, Mystic Mike strikes again.
(laughing)
(dramatic music)
(crowd yelling and applauding)
(crowd cheering and applauding)
(whistling)
I'm enjoying the fruits of my hard work.
Nobody works harder than
me inside the octagon,
outside the octagon.
I am a work horse.
So, I am going to enjoy
the benefits of this life.
I am going to get myself a
big mansion in Las Vegas,
I'm going to get the soft top cars.
I'm going to bring my whole team out.
I'm going to spoil them
and give them this life.
Big steaks that size we're eating
every single night each.
We're eating good, we're living good.
It's human nature.
Some people will sit and
take positivity from that.
They will look at that
and take inspiration and
it will inspire them to
go and push for that.
Others will shell up and critique it
and be negative towards it, but one thing
is for sure.
Those people will stay where they are.
The people who take inspiration
from it will rise up
and also one day experience that life.
So, this is human nature.
Some go one way, some go the other way,
but I am enjoying my
money, my hard earned money
that I have dedicated my life to.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Curling up
away from danger as he's.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
- [Commentator] Roundhouse
turning and he's coming.
(crowd cheering)
This could be it!
Conor McGregor is victorious.
The crowd go absolutely wild.
He gets in what training
that he was looking for.
- [Interviewer] Did you
ever have, let's call it
a normal job, Conor? A 9 to 5?
- Yeah because the Irish
thing is to getting to trade
straightaway.
I was no different.
As soon as I finished school
I was always getting pestered.
What are you doing with your life?
You know?
Doing this, doing that.
They didn't know what it was.
They didn't know MMA was,
they didn't know none of this.
They didn't know I could
make a career out of it.
As far as they were concerned,
mom and dad I'm talking about, I was just
getting into a cage and
fighting with some other guy.
They didn't know nothing about it.
No one did, really, but I knew.
You know what I mean?
I knew and then I ended up getting a trade
just to keep them quiet
because I used to have
a lot of fights with me dad. A lot
- [Interviewer] What trade did you get?
- I ended up getting a trade as a plumber.
Literally opened the back
alleys on the Wicklow Mountains.
I feel that site was one of the biggest
sites in Europe, Kiltearn.
It was right at that skiing place, huge.
And now it's just abandoned.
Now it's just deserted.
So, I used to go up there six o'clock,
five o'clock in the
morning I was on my M-50.
I used to have to walk to the N-4,
about half an hour from me.
Hellish, waiting for some limited guy
that I didn't even know.
He drove on the N-4 and I'd have
to flag him down.
Nightmare, yeah.
Two hours down on the
M-50, two hours back.
Usually 14 hour days and
I was the first year.
So, I had to go and do everything.
I had to go to the shop.
I had to go and get this and get that.
So, I always had trouble with that.
I was like, this isn't for me.
This is not for me.
- [Interviewer] How long did you last?
- I lasted 18 months doing
it, but it was tough.
It wasn't the life for me.
And then John said, because
I was training with John
as well at the time.
And then John got in touch
and says, "I have a show.
On the show would you
like to fight on it?"
And that was it.
I just packed it in, didn't show up.
Me dad used to come in
and punch the hell out me
and try to drag me out of
bed and I just wouldn't go.
And I remember I hadn't
up law for a good few
years removable and that was it.
I just packed it in, quit,
and then focused on training.
I knew what was going to happen.
I knew I was going to
get here, they didn't.
It was a lot of stressful
years, you know what I mean?
A lot of tough times,
but I proved them wrong.
I proved myself right.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Conor McGregor.
- [Commentator] Oh, see Steve O'Keefe.
(crowd cheering)
Need to defend.
Again, the inside elbow's coming in.
- [Commentator] This evening.
Oh, wow, righteously, Steve O'Keefe was
- [Commentator] He was out.
- [Commentator] He was
unconscious from those strikes.
- [Commentator] He's just come back round
and Conor McGregor is.
- Every gym I went to was always,
they had their set way.
Every gym had their set
way of doing things.
Don't do it this way, do it that way.
So, that was just a normal
thing that I thought.
I thought people just
had their own set way
and you must do it that way.
You must stand this way.
You must kick this way.
You must punch this way.
But with John, when I went to John,
I met my coach, John Kavanagh,
at Straight Blast Gym it wasn't like that.
He had a more open mind and he encouraged
different movements and
I'd never experienced
that before.
I'd never heard a coach
say that to me before.
And that stuck in my
head and I talked to him.
And I said, "This guy is
thinking outside the box."
He has a vision that everything works
and he encourages every
movement because ultimately
there is a time and a place
for every single move.
So, I just knew when I met John
and when he spoke it made
complete sense to me and that was it.
I stuck with him and he stuck with me
and the rest is history.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Favorite
striking technique
and we see the punch that lands.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Seconds
away from being stopped.
- [Commentator] That's it.
That's it.
- [Commentator] It is a whopper!
Conor McGregor stops Dennis Siver.
- [Commentator] Look at this.
Look at this.
He's going up to Jose Aldo.
Look at Jose Aldo.
- Gratitude is one of the most strongest
forms of power in attracting good things.
If you truly feel grateful
for the things in your life.
I always felt grateful
for even the small things.
I always used to celebrate
the small things.
Now I might be celebrating
the bigger things,
but I always celebrate
every little good thing
that would happen to me
in my life even before
I had any kind of money or any of that.
I would celebrate and I
would feel grateful for it.
And it just gave me more and
this is exactly the same thing
that's happening right now.
I still remain grateful and more comes.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Hands at his hips.
(crowd cheering)
- [Commentator] Working good.
Just ranked.
- [Commentator] Wow.
That's the real deal, ladies
and gentlemen.
Make no mistake about it,
Conor McGregor is for real.
- [Commentator] An entire
country is standing
on their feet right now.
- [Commentator] He really
did just make it look easy.
He said he would make it look easy,
he made it look easy.
That's the real deal.
- [Commentator] He said, "First
round KO," mark my words.
- [Commentator] We believed him.
I mean, that was just glorious.
- Of course I am familiar
with Muhammad Ali.
You don't just have
him here, he is global.
He is the man.
Muhammad Ali was a guy
that done what had not
been done before.
Change the face,
not only the face of his game,
but the face of the world.
He was outspoken, he fought
for what he believed in.
He was charismatic.
He was a legend, a hero,
and I looked up to him.
One of my first heroes was Muhammad Ali.
When I was 11 years old
there was a group of people
and they tried to attack
me and a fight broke out
and it was just me and one guy
before everyone else jumped in on me,
but we were fighting each other.
And I slipped a punch and
I shuffled my shoulders
and said, "Muhammad
Ali!" And threw a shot.
And he rolled under the
shot but fell into a knee
and I ended up on top of him.
So, I'm out there calling
myself Muhammad Ali
and I'm punching him in the head.
Then somebody came in and tried to kick me
and then a whole group of them came in
and it was just a big fight, but it was me
against six of them.
And I ended up getting my ass whooped.
- [Interviewer] But that
first guy, you whooped him out
and you said, "Muhammad Ali".
- I done the Ali shuffle.
I'm only 11 years old.
I done the Ali shuffle, threw a left hook.
He rolled under the left hook.
It was good of him to roll.
He saw it coming and rolled under it,
but he rolled right into a knee.
I was prepared.
I was studying tape, so yeah.
No, so definitely Muhammad
Ali was a hero of mine.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Conor's
12 wins, 11 are knockouts
- [Commentator] Caught him
with the uppercut there.
- [Commentator] Are knockouts
and he almost did it again
- [Commentator] Going backwards.
- [Commentator] Look at that upper.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Uppercut.
- [Commentator] Looking to finish it here.
This is why everyone's been
talking about Conor McGregor.
- [Commentator] It's all over.
Connor McGregor another
first round win, wow!
Ultra impressive UFC debut.
- [Commentator] That is
exactly why he's so dangerous.
- I don't like to think too far ahead.
- [Interviewer] So, you haven't thought
alternative careers
- No, I don't like thinking too far ahead.
People set goals, long
distance goals and shit.
That's too much for me.
I already feel like I'm living it
and then I just carry on.
I carry on day by day already
living the final goal,
the goal of being the world champion.
I already carry myself
like I'm a world champion.
I already speak like I'm a
world champion and that's it.
I just carry on day by day
so I'll take it as it comes.
Again, like I said, you're
asking me about the future.
I'll let you know a little bit closer,
you know what I mean?
All I can see right now is the gold.
That's all I can see.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Outside strikes back.
- [Commentator] It was
so very well executed.
Ivan Buchinger having a horribly.
(crowd cheering)
How very selfish.
- [Commentator] With just a few shots
Buchinger's completely out of it.
- [Commentator] What a reaction!
What a spectacular
knockout by Conor McGregor
as we are bombarded with his fans around
the coveted position.
- [Commentator] Covered
in rather a lot of beer
as well, John.
- [Commentator] Ivan Buchinger.
- First, like most fights I
usually come out maybe two,
three week before, but
every time I come back it
seems to be a little bit
more crazy with the fans,
you know?
They treat me like I'm one of their own.
Then I've been driving to
the gym every day and I drive
past this guy's apartment.
And on the balcony he has like Irish flags
and a cardboard cutout of
me sitting on his balcony.
So, now we're going to
go drop in to him and see
what he's about and meet one of the fans.
- [Man] I'd like you to meet Mr. McGregor.
- [Conor] What's up?
- [Fan] Holy shit, man.
- [Conor] How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- [Conor] Not bad.
(laughing)
- [Fan] This is awesome.
- I'm going to wave at this man.
I drove by a couple times and it's like,
What the? I thought I was
seeing things at first.
- [Fan] No, it's been up
since your Max Holloway
fight, man. I set
- No way.
Are you looking forward
to the fight next week?
- [Fan's Girlfriend] Oh yeah.
- [Fan] Please, are you kidding me?
I got my shirt in my wardrobe in there.
I got your shoes.
You see them right through there.
- [Conor] What, the Reeboks?
- [Fan] Yeah, it says "Champ" on the back.
(laughing)
- I don't even have
them, they're re demos.
They are unbelievable, man.
- [Fan] I'm telling you, man.
- Yeah, honestly now that's unbelievable.
I'm going to put on a
show for you specifically.
- [Fan] Thank you so much, yeah.
Every Saturday before the
fight I put up my cardboard
cutout, I put up the
flag, I put up the banner.
And the only thing I can
say, and I hope Conor
sees this, is that that
feeling he had with Jose Aldo
when he knocked him out
and he became the champ,
hands down, that's what
I felt like tonight.
Like, that's how amazing it was
and I really hope he sees that.
I think he saw that on my
face and there we go again,
see it's going again, but
that's the best I can say.
I'm enamored right now, man, I'm shaking.
I'm acting like such a
little baby and crying.
(laughing)
- [Conor] I appreciate it, man.
Honestly, I'm glad I could
make your day, alright?
I appreciate the support
of all the fans out here
and all over the world.
I never take it for granted.
I use it as motivation,
so I am extremely grateful
to the fans.
Thank you so much.
- [Fan's Girlfriend] See you. Bye. Thanks.
(upbeat music)
- [Commentator] Listen to this place.
- [Commentator] Oh, big shot by McGregor!
- [Commentator] Look at the clock.
Ten seconds.
- [Commentator] Can he finish him here?
It's all over!
Conor McGregor is a UFC
Interim Featherweight Champion!
- [Commentator] Wow, wow
(crowd cheering)
Wow.
Wow, unbelievable.
He did it.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Mr.13forTaylor asked me to.
So, if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next,
leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Conor's Top Ten Rules
meant the most to you,
is going to have the
biggest impact on your
life or your business.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(jet flying)
There's parents coming in
with their kids from like
that height bringing them into the gym.
Their mom and dad by their
side, encouraging it.
I was never like that.
That's going to go to the next level
when you have the parents
encouraging the dream.
Again, people can say
it's barbaric and martial
arts is barbaric, or this game
it's too much.
It's two men beating
each other or whatever.
The martial arts life will
give you a discipline,
will give you dedication,
will give you a drive
that you won't get nowhere else.
So, whatever these kids
that come in at that size
with their parents,
whatever they decide to do,
whether they decide to
conquer the martial arts
world, the fighting game,
or whether they want
to go and conquer the business world.
Whatever they decide to do,
training for combat sport,
training martial arts will
give them that confidence
to go and excel in anything.
So, people can criticize
about it all they want,
but the results speak for themselves.
And seeing these little
kids coming in this size,
it's good times, good times ahead I see.